AND NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY BLACK
AND WTF: HALLOWEEN EDITION.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: HALLOWEEN IS ALMOST
HERE.
I KNOW BECAUSE I WENT TO
DISNEYLAND THE OTHER DAY AND
THEY TURNED THE HAUNTED
MANSIONED INTO NIGHTMARE BEFORE
CHRISTMAS HAUNTED MANSION --
WHICH IS AWESOME.
NOW, COSTUMES HAVE BEEN AROUND
SINCE LIKE, THE 30s.
AND MAYBE IT WAS THE FACT THE
PCP WAS USED TO SOOTHE A
TEETHING BABY OR COCAIN WAS AN
OPTION AT THE SODA FOUNTAIN --
ALL I KNOW IS PEOPLE WORE MESSED
UP [BEEP].
THANKS TO RECENT POSTS BY
BUZZFEED AND IMGUR, COSTUMES ARE
TIMELESSY PRESERVED.
SO IN THE SPIRIT OF HALLOWEEN, I
WANT EVERYONE TO REACH UNDER
YOUR LECTURN, GRAB YOUR
FLASHLIGHT, AND TURN IT ON.
NOW BRING THE STUDIO LIGHTS
DOWN, CHILDREN.
AND FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU
TO CHANNEL YOUR INNER VINCENT
PRICE AND GIVE ME A TRULY
CHILLING LINE FROM AN OLD
TIME RADIO SHOW FEATURING THESE
CHARACTERS I'M ABOUT TO SHOW
YOU.
FIRST UP, THESE TWO TROUBLE
MAKERS.
OH THE HORROR.
YES, ALISON BECKER.
>> THIS IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
YOUR WOMEN IF YOU ALLOW THEM TO
VOTE.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: POINTS.
ROB CORRDRY.
>> COME CARVE A PUMPKIN WITH US,
DANNY, FOREVER AND EVER, OR AT
LEAST UNTIL HALLOWEEN IS OVER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS DROOGE.
YES, ALISON.
>> THE PROJECT RUNWAY GHOST TO
SEEK REVENGE ON TIM GUN FOR
TELLING HIM THAT HE COULDN'T
MAKE A TINY HAT WORK.
>> Chris: POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: MAKE IT WORK.
DANNAH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN, PHARELL.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> WOW.
>> Chris: ROB.
>> I SWEAR I'M NOT A
TRICK-OR-TREATER.
I AM HERE TO ROB YOU.
>> Chris: LAST ONE.
THIS SAD CLOWN.
YES DANNAH.
>> DID SOMEBODY HERE ORDER AN
UBER.
[LAUGHING]